Here's my solution to the findtags problem.
I decided to do it just using regular expressions.
Why don't I make that explicit and import the regular expression module,
but then I broke up my regular expression, because they can get long and complicated.
I said there is a part where I'm parsing the parameters,
and that's one or more word characters, an equal sign, and then a quoted string.
A quote character, 0 or more non-quote characters, followed by a quote character.
Then that whole thing we can have zero or more parameters.
The thing that made it complicated is I've got to throw in optional spaces in multiple positions--
" \s* " means zero or more spaces.
That defines a set of parameters.
Then the tag is the angle bracket, maybe some spaces, word character--
like the a or the table tag, then the parameters, then maybe some more spaces,
and then the close. The close is an angle bracket.
I allowed an optional slash-angle bracket there.
Now that I've defined this regular expression in tags,
then I just re.findall of the tags in the text.